In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 28, on which we commemorate the Holy Nine
martyrs of Sysicus.
On the 28th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Nine Holy martyrs of Sysicus.
Thognevis, Rufus, Antipater, Thogdistus, Artemas, Magnus, Theodoulos, Thalmasios and Philemon.
These holy and glorious martyrs, born in different places, were arrested in the town
of Sysicus, now Balikisar, in the Helispont, in a time of persecution.
Interrogated about their faith, they replied with courage, mocking the idolatrous superstitions.
They were then submitted to various tortures, but they preferred to offer themselves as a living
sacrifice to the true God, by being beheaded, rather than to submit to the worship of idols.
They therefore became, after their deaths, invisible physicians who healed the ills of those who
drew near to their tombs with faith.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.